well president Trump's back-and-forth
with governor's about how and when they
will reopen their states has taken
another turn this morning after telling
governor's quote they'd called the shots
the president is now encouraging some
states to quote liber8
his calls on Twitter are coming even
though they're abiding by his
administration's own guidelines
Nikole Killion is at the White House
this morning with that part of the story
Nicole good morning good morning to you
Michele president Trump says some states
have gone too far with their
restrictions and thinks those who are
protesting them are doing the right
thing as protesters in various states
rallied against stay at home orders
President Trump
backed their calls in a series of tweets
he exclaimed liberate Minnesota Michigan
and Virginia these are people expressing
their views I see where they are and I
see the way they're working they seem to
be very responsible people to me but
it's they've been treated a little bit
rough the Democratic governors of those
states were quick to respond I hope that
it's not encouraging more protests that
will probably take longer than a
two-word tweet but I think there's a
responsibility to tell us that if
there's I'd like to know what they think
we could have done differently
the president's liberation calls came a
day after he laid out a three-step plan
to gradually reopen the economy leaving
the decision up to governor's how many
times do you want me to say thank you
sparred with the president over the
federal response the president back
Cuomo should spend more time doing and
less time complaining if he's sitting
home watching TV maybe he should get up
and go to work right many governors and
medical experts have insisted more
testing is needed before restrictions
can be eased but the White House insists
it's adequate we have a sufficient
amount of testing to meet the
requirements of a phase 1 reopening with
more than 22 million people out of work
the largest number since the Great
Depression the president blamed
Democrats for holding up additional
funding for a small business loan
program after it ran out this week with
Nancy Pelosi she's away on a vacation or
something we all want the initiative to
succeed and so hopefully we can come to
bipartisan agreement very soon
Democrats want Hospital funding added to
the loan package the president and even
some congressional Republicans say
they'd be okay with that later today the
vice president travels to Colorado for
an Air Force commencement the president
said he also looks forward to the day
when he can eventually travel more
including to campaign rallies Dana we
all look forward to traveling more there
is no doubt about that Nicole thank you